In more detail we can express
the simplex algorithm as follows.
First, calculate Rd.
If Rd is non-positive,
well then we've done as well as we can,
and we can just return
our current solution,
B inverse times b in the basic
variables, and zero elsewhere.
Otherwise, pick q such that
the qth element of rd is positive,
and then let dq be the qth column of D.
This is the column that we
want to bring in to the bases.
Next, calculate this column U
as B inverse times the qth
column of the Matrix D.
If U doesn't have any positive entries,
we can report that
the problem is unbounded.
We can just increase the value of x
that corresponded to this positive rdq.
As much as we want.
If that's not the case,
then we find the i which minimizes
this ratio of Vi by Yi,
where the ui is positive.
This tells us which constraint
we're going to run into first.
And we let bi be the ith column of B.
We then swap out bi from the basis, and
swap dq in, and
we keep on repeating this procedure.